every Veterans Day American flags are
placed on the graves of the Southern
Nevada Veterans Memorial Cemetery in
Boulder City but this year there's a
problem that's going to take all of us
to help solve Madison Kimbrough there
with the details
come November 10th a section of the
cemetery will be covered in American
flags to honor veterans who have passed
away but some of those flags are missing
now a woman whose father has been laid
to rest here wants to find them I
started with two lonely flights in 2019
2020 I did
1440. last year we were able to honor 5
000 men and women Don Cramer hoping to
keep the tradition alive as every
Veterans Day she comes to Southern
Nevada Veterans Memorial Cemetery in
Boulder City and places American flags
on the grave sites a time for her to
honor her late father a former Marine
and others who served our country last
year while packing up the flags a
volunteer offered to store them for her
since Cramer now lives out of town but
fast forward to this year and the flags
are nowhere to be found after she lost
the woman's contact I had spoken with
the woman who graciously offered to take
all these flags for us on her own dime
come out to the cemetery and pick them
up and to house them for a year for us
and
um I I'm ashamed to say I've lost
contact information with my phone Lynn
Taylor a fellow volunteer with Kramer
hopes that someone sees this and is able
to find the missing Flags the hope is to
place 8 000 of them this Veterans Day
we're asking in a plea type way to
please contact us or Don or whomever to
let us know that the flags are in a safe
keeping place that they will be here for
Veterans Day if you have any information
as to where these flags may be we have
contact information up on our website
that you can reach to now the placing of
these flags is set to take place on
Thursday November 10th at 1 pm and they
are still looking for volunteers
reporting in Boulder City Madison kimpro
8 News Now
so hopefully this story will help these
two ladies find each other if not Kramer
says if you'd like to donate Flags you
can do so at the Ace Hardware store in
Boulder City as they are also helping
Supply the event and will also help
transport the flags on November 10th